Leute was soll ich sagen ein Traum oh
das ist so lecker mega geil Leute mega
geil
[Musik]
hi Zusammen wir machen heute etwas was
ich schon immer vorhatte und ich in
Dubai noch mal dran erinnert wurde und
haben sie meinte du musst das nachmachen
aber das ist einfach ein Keks
okay einfach ein flacher
schokogeschäft
ganz ehrlich mach das mal nach das ist
richtig geil
und zwar ist es ein riesen Cookie in
einer Pfanne gefüllt mit einer leckeren
creme ich nehme heute die spekulos
Karamellcreme und on top noch mal Eis
also richtig foodporn einfach etwas was
man sich gönnt und ich starte direkt und
schreibe euch die ganz genauen
Mengenangaben unten in die Infobox gar
nicht lang fackeln Kopf im Nacken und
loslegen mein Lieblingsspruch bei
schnellen Rezepten so da gebe ich jetzt
einfach zerlassene Butter habe ich in
der Mikrowelle bei geringen aber zwar
gemacht in meine große Schüssel da kommt
das brauner Zucker mit dazu das schmeckt
nämlich schön karamellig
Vanilleextrakt und Salz Salz da dürfte
nicht drauf verzichten das macht den
Geschmack einfach noch mal rund und dann
verrühren wir das einfach kurz
[Musik]
so jetzt in dem Moment denkt man sich
vielleicht oh mega flüssige Masse die
soll daraus jemals ein Keks werden aber
vertraut mir Leute jetzt gehen wir an
der Stelle schon unsere
schokoladen-chanks dazu ich nehme immer
das was ich in der Schublade habe
könntet auch Drops nehmen ihr könnt doch
einfach Kuvertüre fein hacken ich habe
jetzt hier die Schoko Chunks in
Vollmilch und der Zartbitter da gebe ich
jetzt aber noch nicht alles rein ich
will nur dass ich das erstmal gut
verbindet in den Rest gebe ich später
und top weil das dann einfach auch
optisch noch mal schick aussieht das
ganze noch mal kurz verrühren und ich
muss sagen es hört fühlt sich immer noch
so komisch an zu sagen ja ich war ja in
Dubai weil ich eigentlich nie nach Dubai
wollte und haben sah wollte halt immer
unbedingt das Wald seinen Traum und ich
habe gedacht okay komm ich lass mich mal
mitziehen ich finde das mal einmal schön
zu sehen aber ich müsste jetzt kein
zweites Mal hin das ist so meine Meinung
zu Dubai ihr könnt mir gerne schreiben
ob ihr Reisepläne habt und wohin es dann
geht und ich verrühre in der
Zwischenzeit Backpulver mit dem Mehl und
ganz wichtig das ist der
ehrenamerikanisches Rezept und du da
machst cream oft Tatar auch was mit der
Konsistenz des Keks cream of Tatar ist
Weinstein es gibt auch
Weinsteinbackpulver im Supermarkt das
ist nicht dasselbe ist eine ganz andere
Zusammensetzung und Weinstein kann man
so vielseitig einsetzen ihr braucht doch
nie viel davon so eine Tüte hält echt
ewig und ich wollte halt unbedingt weil
ich weiß dass es auch sehr schwer zu
finden im Supermarkt das unbedingt im
Shop aufnehmen und das gebe ich jetzt
hier einfach noch mit rein ihr könnt es
so viele Leute ich könnt euch ein ganzes
Video ich glaube ich mache euch ein
ganzes Video darüber ihr könnt das bei
der Reinigung anwenden dadurch wird
Sahnesteif haben man könnte damit auch
Früchte etc säubern man kann damit wenn
ihr Obst blanchiert damit es einfach die
Farbe behält könnte man Weinstein
benutzen es ist so vielseitig und halt
eben hier auch im Gebäck und habe ich
das einmal kurz vorab verrührt gibt das
einmal komplett mit rein und dann
verbinden wir alles zu einer Masse
[Musik]
Ofen vorheizen das ist so ein
Blitzrezept dass ich das vergessen habe
so jetzt aber erstmal die Sachen
rausholen kennt ihr diesen Gag bei
Ausländern sind immer tausend Sachen im
Ofen auf einmal kommt so ein Bügeleisen
raus bügelbretten Koffer an Staubsauger
diesmal alles rausholen hier achso
natürlich gar nicht gesagt wie viel Grad
180 Grad Ober- und Unterhitze der muss
unbedingt vorgeheizt sein so jetzt könnt
ihr euch entscheiden welche Größe ihr
nehmen weil sie brauchen erstmal eine
Pfanne die Backofen geeignet ist ich
habe jetzt einmal die 20er die würde ich
gerne benutzen weil es gerne ein
bisschen höher mag ihr könnt aber auch
mit dem Rezept die 24er nehmen und dann
ist es einfach ein bisschen flacher da
braucht sie so ungefähr 20 bis 24
Minuten aber ihr müsst selber ein Auge
drauf haben das ist nicht zu
dunkelbraun wird weil dann ist es
meistens schon zu trocken es darf ruhig
noch goldbraun sein und hier braucht es
auf jeden Fall ich denke mal so 8 bis 10
Minuten länger aber die genaue Backzeit
blenden wir euch ja immer ein so und
jetzt nehmen wir uns die Hälfte des
Teiges mit dem sauberen Fingern
natürlich besser wenn ihr eine Pfanne
habt die extrem gut beschichtet ist ja
ja Schleichwerbung für meine Pfannen
aber hier brauche ich absolut gar kein
Fett oder sonst was gibt es einfach so
rein drücke es flach an gerne so ein
bisschen am Rand entlang denn gleich
kommt ja noch das gab es in Dubai nicht
übrigens ich habe mir das Video extra
noch mal angeguckt und so ein bisschen
enttäuscht weil ich möchte gerne innen
drin auch noch die
spekulos Füllung haben und dritte später
noch ein bisschen was oben drüber und
meinen Spekulatius Aufstrich könnt ihr
am besten jetzt rein geben wenn ich so
ein bisschen erwärmt da ist ja so zeige
ich euch mal die Konsistenz eigentlich
auch schon cremig aber wenn ihr es bei
ungefähr 600 Watt für 30 Sekunden in die
Mikrowelle gibt ohne Deckel könnt das
einfach ganz einfach dosieren und nicht
wundern Leute das hier ist das alte
Design wir finden nämlich dass es also
es schmeckt halt wirklich nach
Spekulatius und Karamell und nicht rein
nach Spekulatius daher haben wir es
einfach noch mal abgeändert in
los Caramel und das Design hat sich ein
bisschen verändert und es ist keine
Limited Edition mehr dieser kleine rote
Punkt hier mit Limited Edition ist weg
auf jeden Fall hat es geschafft ins
dauer-sortiment zu kommen weil ihr so
verrückt danach seid
[Musik]
so jetzt habe ich oben noch mal den
Deckel zugemacht mit dem Cookie Teig da
könnt ihr einfach so fleckchenweise
arbeiten und das dann vorsichtig
zusammendrücken einfach damit jetzt die
speculusfüllung nicht Austritt wenn sie
auch so das auch nicht schlimm mit on
top kommt der eh noch mal was und jetzt
könnt ihr wie gesagt noch mal die
restlichen Drops oder Chunks obendrauf
geben ich habe mich jetzt hier doch für
runde entschieden für oben drüber
einfach für die Optik so ein paar nach
oben drauf einfach damit man weiß okay
das erwartet da auf jeden Fall noch was
schokoladiges und dann kommt es in den
Backofen da unbedingt drauf achten dass
ihr bei meinen Fund den Henkel abnimmt
denn die Pfanne an sich ist Backofen
geeignet auch bis 300 Grad mit Deckel
bis 240 Grad ihr wisst bescheid aber
einmal den Griff abnehmen so und jetzt
kommt in den Ofen und wir sehen uns
gleich wieder
[Musik]
also soll ich jetzt ehrlich sein ich bin
ehrlich ich habe gerade schon weil wir
erstmal mal die Fotos Videos mal so ein
bisschen geschnitten es ist so lecker
aber ich muss jetzt hier noch mal
verkosten es schmeckt warm und kalt ich
habe sie nicht gerade warm probiert und
noch kalt und mit Eis getoppt und
natürlich noch mal der spekulos
karamellchen getoppt das ist einfach
Leute was soll ich sagen ein Traum und
bitte zählt keine Kalorien heute
oh das ist so lecker ich muss sagen es
kommt extrem dieser spekulos Geschmack
durch wenn der nicht wäre mir weiß auch
lecker aber vielleicht ein bisschen
langweilig findet dieser spekulus
Geschmack macht es einfach aus der ist
ja auch im Teig verarbeitet und hat noch
mal on top mega geil Leute mega geil
also ich für meinen Teil verabschiede
mich jetzt ich bin sehr glücklich und
werde mir auf jeden Fall noch ein zwei
Schaufeln gönnen also bis dann tschüss
[Musik]